kinder war das aufregend diese woche
oder eine expertenkommission hat
verkündet welche region für ein atommüll
endlager in frage kommen ergebnis 54 von
deutschland sind noch im rennen ja was
für ein gesegnetes land meine wir haben
alle drei passenden wirtsgesteine ton
granit und salz toll
er muss halt eine weile halten das alte
müll grab und zwar eine million jahre
ist kein witz
solange strahlt das hochradioaktive zeug
im jahr eine million 2022 wie die welt
am wohl aus hieß es
ich vermute bis dahin hat sich die
menschheit doch längst selbst ausradiert
das was dann noch übrig sind mutierte
riesen kakerlaken und natürlich das zdf
bares für rares läuft noch in einer
million jahren und zwar nach einer
wiederholung von inspector barnaby warum
soll es den kakerlaken besser gehen als
uns so immerhin das ist die gute
nachricht suchen wir jetzt das endlager
endlich nach wissenschaftlichen
kriterien 30 jahre lang wurde ja nur
gorleben erkundet für das man sich aus
rein politischen gründen entschieden hat
weil es so schön nah an der zonengrenze
lag damals 1973 als das zdf noch
objektiv berichtet hat der dringend
notwendige 50 milliardenschwere bau
dieser anlagen aber wird nicht zuletzt
durch den massiven protest von
umweltschutz fanatikern verzögert sie
vermuten nicht wieder gutzumachende
schäden in der natur und malen unsinnige
vorstellungen von atom- gefahren auf
ihre fahnen und siehe da die
ungewaschenen hippies hatten völlig
recht gorleben seit dieser woche von der
liste gestrichen
die deckschichten sind nicht dicht genug
haben die hippies schon immer gesagt
wollte aber niemand hören ist abgesehen
davon muss das zeugs einfach neben 27
tausend kubikmeter atommüll kannst du
schlecht zum wertstoffhof bringt die
meckern da bis 2031 wird weiter erkundet
dann fällt die entscheidung ich frage
mich nur warum geht das nicht schneller
könnte nicht keine ahnung günther jauch
eine spezialausgabe machen wer wird
endlager oder hier noch eine idee wir
verlosen das ja natürlich
da ziehen doch gerade überall diese
lotterie nervensägen durch die lande
die deutsche post code lotterie
aufgepasst deutschland gleich klingelt
hallo hier ist die deutsche post com
lotterie und du erfährst der
postleitzahl wurde als endlager standort
gezogen
endlich ein eigenes endlager cool die
deutsche post lotterie wer jetzt noch
die tür aufmacht ist selber schuld
so machen wir uns nichts vor
am ende muss eine region unser aller
atom sünden auf sich nehmen irgendwer
hat die arschkarte steht so im
endlagersuchgesetz dass alle
bundesländer unterschrieben haben auch
bayern dieselben bayern die jetzt stink
sauer sind weil zwei drittel ihres
schönen freistaats atommüll tauglich
sind ganz offiziell seit dieser woche ja
markus söder guckt jetzt von morgens bis
abends beleidigt auf die neue landkarte
mit den endlagern in spa und kann es gar
nicht fassen ich meine das betrifft das
ist ganz unterfranken komplett das ist
ganz oberfranken komplett das ist ganz
mittelfranken komplett nach super dann
kriegt bayer neben drei endlager wenn
das so ist in söders koalitionsvertrag
mit den freien wählern steht der
wirklich unverschämte satz zitat wir
sind überzeugt dass bayern kein
geeigneter standort für ein atomendlager
ist ja sagt loos sie in die anderen
länder übrigens exakt genauso krise die
bayernlb an rum weil gorleben raus ist
das sei doch ein ich zitiere so dass
umweltminister schlüsselfertiges
endlager sagen die geologen was anderes
und der bayerische vize könig greift die
wissenschaft sogar frontal an
nicht sagen voraus dass auf diesem weg
in den nächsten jahrzehnten wieder
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse fünfmal
revidiert werden wie am ende 2 20 50
wieder ohne endlager standort dastehen
werden was willst du denn wieder dort
stehen werden wissenschafts bashing im
trump zeitalter toll ganz toll der
aiwanger ist landwirt entschuldigung
agraringenieur wieso erklärt der jetzt
den geologen ihre arbeit
höchste zeit für ein neues wissens
format im kinderfernsehen
wie will smith
heute was ist eigentlich der unterschied
zwischen einem geologen und einem bauern
gute frage ob denn da klingt ja erst mal
vieles ähnlich steine schweine zum
beispiel der unterschied ist der geologe
hat studiert einer richtigen uni du hast
an der fachhochschule gelernt wo der an
knopf und einer melkmaschine ist ruby
deswegen ist es doof wenn du den
geologen seine wissenschaft erklärt der
geologe erklärt die ihr ja auch nicht wo
du deine gülle hin spritzen darfst denkt
mal drüber nach kobe
jetzt ist
jacobi die bürger die am ende den müll
kriegen müssen akzeptieren dass die
suche nach wissenschaftlichen kriterien
läuft wenn irgendwelche politiker diese
kriterien jetzt schon in frage stellen
ist das regelrecht fahrlässig und das
hässliche wort um zu vermeiden huby
warum glauben die bayern eigentlich dass
ausgerechnet sie zu gut sind für
atommüll
da müsste man den jetzt schon aus
prinzip das endlager verpassen ehrlich
und weißt du was wenn wir schon dabei
sind am besten auch noch sämtliche
leeren batterien und altöl plus alle
problem wölfe vergelt's gott und schrott
mit dir du land der bayern
es ist ja so auf der ganzen welt gibt es
immer noch kein richtiges endlager
nirgendwo trotzdem diskutierten man
interessanterweise ernsthaft über ein
comeback der atomkraft und zwar als
rettung in der klimakrise meine klar
also ist eine co2 arme energieformen
atom allerdings mit gewissen risiken
ich sage nur tschernobyl ja wir stehen
jetzt im grunde genommen von dem
reaktorblock zu 150 meter entfernt der
damals explodiert ist und danach durch
den brand natürlich auch noch weiter
beschädigt wurde
ja hier ist noch strahlung also ich habe
hier mal dieses messgerät dass wir bei
uns haben und das schlägt auch natürlich
deutlich an
ich mache jetzt nun mal während der
schalter aus und stört das so das ist
mein sender komplett verstrahlt aber
hauptsache der ton stimmt kommt die
atomenergie zurück wir schalten live zur
firma terrapower in seattle usa
dort entwickelt man ganz neue angeblich
sichere reaktoren finanziert worden ist
jetzt kein witz bill gates dr dennis
knossalla forscht mit der knossalla ich
denke bill gates foltert den ganzen tag
kinder in unterirdischen verließen um
was er zirbeldrüse drogen zu gewinnen
wieso der noch zeit für atomforschung
[Gelächter]
nein wir arbeiten im schichtbetrieb
kinder foltern ist nachts tagsüber bauen
wir neue reaktoren warum weil die welt
sie braucht die gletscher schmelzen der
wald brennt und was macht dieser
neubauer und dummes gesicht nur
atomstrom rettet den planeten
wir müssen endlich zurück zur
unschuldigen atom begeisterung der
sechziger
der volksmund spricht von atommüll in
großen gelben tonnen werden diese
abfälle
transportiert die strahlung ist sehr
gering und somit weniger gefährlich als
manche glauben der kameramann kann
unmittelbar an die tonne heran
der äußerst empfindliche film wird von
der strahlung nicht getroffen dem
kameramann geht es super
der hatte später eine fünfköpfige
familie mit zwei kindern alter
kernphysiker witz ja nicht mal die
stromkonzerne wollen noch atom weil sich
nicht rechnet ein neues akw in england
liegt jetzt schon bei 26 milliarden euro
ja genau der engländer machen wir es
lieber alle wie die deutschen und
setzten bis 2038 weiter auf hochmoderne
braunkohle
wenn ihr in dem tempo weiter macht er
findet ihr bald den buchdruck man
schätzt rund 800.000 menschen sterben
weltweit jedes jahr durch kohle rauch
und seine schadstoffe dass sie mit der
kohle ist doch nur eine übergangslösung
wir deutschen bauen jetzt mit hochdruck
windräder stromspeicher neue leitungen
dann wird deutschland komplett mit
erneuerbaren versorgt
[Gelächter]
das macht atomenergie noch nicht
sicherer knossalla teurer strom +
atommüll plus unfallrisiko jaja aber
nicht mehr lange
ich sage nur reaktor generation 4
die babys laufen mit alten brennstäben
produzieren so gut wie keinen müll und
können einfach abgeschaltet werden da
passiert weniger unfälle als mit dem
thermomix außerdem entwickeln wir jetzt
mini reaktoren nur noch so groß wie ein
einfamilienhaus und mein neuester clou
das mikro akw für die hosentasche
kein modell ist ein voll
funktionsfähiges atomkraftwerk lädt
nebenbei noch mein handy auf das ist die
zukunft wege generation 4 habe ich
darüber gelesen noch sind das aber alles
nur rechenmodelle knossalla kein mensch
weiß wie sicher die teile im
dauerbetrieb funktionieren ist klar
verfeuert er gern einmal weiter eure
briketts das auf
ach nee die blöden urans lecken kriegt
man so schlecht raus das ist mir leid
denn das knossalla
ja it-service beweise sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung